two of the oldest teams in the LCS might
be history with TSM reportedly
considering an exit and carologic gaming
confirming that they will cease
operations and shut down now with one or
two of these franchise spots hitting the
open market and viewership settling
around half of its European counterpart
I think it's fair to ask again is the
LCS dying plus counter logic gaming fans
will obviously be devastated by this
news and some of those people have been
watching this team since the beginning
so what can they expect let's take a
look
[Music]
LCS viewership has been a hot topic for
a while so guys LCS is dying like the
viewership is absolutely dying it's
there's no there's no denying it that
everyone knows it everyone can feel it
that clip was from nine months ago and
the viewership Trend hasn't reversed but
it feels a lot more real now that we're
seeing orgs actually heading for the
door so I think it's fair to ask how bad
is this really and what could be done to
bring the league back to those hallowed
early days before I get started in
Earnest I just want to say that you may
have already seen Danny's TSM video and
if you have great and I'm not going to
fully retread that here so you don't
have to worry for the purposes of this
video it's enough to know that a report
from Sports business journals Kevin hit
said that TSM was pausing Esports
operations and were even considering
turning their back on the league that
gave them their start the LCS so we
don't really know what TSM is planning
to do for certain but a full a message
from Reginald after that report seems
fully compatible with it it doesn't seem
to directly contradict it in any way
what we do know is that in clg's case at
least things are a lot more concrete a
report from Travis Gafford claimed
initially that all staff minus the
League of Legends vertical would be laid
off and that NRG would have some
involvement with the league side of
things the League of Legends verticals
seemingly is headed towards NRG it's
unclear to me the exact details but I've
just been told that NRG will have some
sort of
uh involvement with the League of
Legends team maybe an acquisition and
then once they can change the name over
to NRG that's what it'll be energy
Esports you may remember was actually
part of the league in 2016. before
franchising was implemented they fielded
a couple different rosters notably
including GBM but they were relegated
from the league and CLG seemingly
confirmed the DraStic moves to Alexander
Lee of digiday although they offered no
additional detail about what was
happening to summarize TSM a team that
built its reputation in early North
American League of Legends I bet in some
ways exists because of it is considering
turning their back on that league and
counter logic gaming their early North
American Rivals and again a foundational
org for this league have confirmed that
they're leaving in fact it's not clear
if the counter logic gaming brand will
even exist anymore now I want to talk
more about the org itself in a bit but
first let's turn our attention to the
league itself it's no secret that times
are tough in Esports we've seen reports
of OverWatch League teams collectively
bargaining with Activision for some sort
of relief in the face of insufficient
revenue streams layoffs have ravaged
both organizations and the media that
cover them and with sponsors either
reconsidering or else getting hauled in
by U.S federal authorities decisions
will be made in the coming months that
could reshape a lot of what we know as
Esports so now one or two spots becoming
available will test exactly how bright
the future is for the LCS in the past
the buy-in was reportedly in the tens of
millions the question now is is there
anyone who wants to buy into today's LCS
at that price and today's LCS is doing a
lot of the heavy lifting in that
sentence because people are just
concerned about the current state of
things and wonder where it will all go
from here in terms of viewership it's
been pretty consistently around 100 to
120 000 average viewers for about a year
now and for both average and Peak
viewers they're around half the size of
the LEC now we should be honest those
are actually still pretty good numbers
for a league especially when we're
talking about a regional league and one
that frankly hasn't done that well
recently but it kind of seems like a
plateau at least for the moment and if
that doesn't change well obviously
that'll have impacts on things like
advertising and sponsorships now listen
I can forgive LCS fans for not exactly
being exhilarated by the level of play
on offer no hate to the players mind you
I just think fans are pretty much
accepting of the fact at this point that
the region is struggling has been
struggling for a while and there doesn't
seem to be a clear path to end that
phenomenon in the early days of law
Esports North America played a central
role they were a special part of this
developing League this developing
landscape they made it better they
helped Kendall one of the first
International rivalries and those
players were some of the game's early
brightest stars I I think it's fair to
say that Annie's influence on the game
has diminished since that time sure part
of it is the losing and with some rare
exceptions they don't win a whole lot
outside the continent at this point so
to be clear I'm not saying that there
was more money in the scene back then I
don't think that's true at all nor am I
saying that things were somehow better
back then I'm not waxing nostalgic I
promise you na just had a bigger piece
of the pie back then right and they
haven't done a good job of protecting
that portion so here we are outside of
some isolated moments that I mentioned
there just hasn't been a lot of cause
for Hope for n a fans and if competitive
success contributes to viewership in
some way well that factor won't be
affecting viewership at least in the
near future I could be wrong I would
love to be wrong
but yeah if we accept that at least
hypothetically then what does it mean
for the cost of an LCS spot I guess what
I'm saying is now that we know about
where viewership has settled at least
for the moment
are those 10 or 13 million dollar
buy-ins
actually good for today's league and I'm
not clear that they can be justified
when the league was franchised in 2018
the numbers were about double what they
are right now and of course those
investors didn't invest believing that
it would shrink by half they were hoping
it would grow and like growth could
still happen I'm not being a Doomer
about all of it I just don't understand
exactly how it would happen and how
they'd even get back to those 2018
levels at this point listen predicting
how all this stuff plays out is probably
a Fool's errand but we should remember
that Riot does hold some power if
organizations are struggling to make a
sustainable go of things in the current
situation Riot could step in and offer
some relief if that's a thing that they
want to do see you again the OverWatch
league case that we mentioned earlier
and finally I just want to say that if
we don't hear the cost of the spot when
it is sold then that means it sold for
less than the normal amount at least in
my opinion e if it sells for more it
will get publicized I guarantee you even
if there's rules of the contract that
say that they can't talk about it
sold for more we'll hear about it what
happens next to the LCS will inevitably
be the opening of a new chapter in its
history it's not clear exactly what that
will look like but in my opinion if it
ends up with teams making sustainable
money Riot being happy with the
situation then that's a good foundation
on which to grow finally I promise to
talk about CLG and for me they're
absolutely one of the OG orgs they were
part of what made na League So Exciting
in those early days they were constant
Rivals with TSM and although the matchup
often went to their opponents CLG had
their moments too I mean I'm speechless
it's been years of Blood Sweat and Tears
for all of us sorry my throat's shot
um but it's it's truly magical to be
here thank you plus they were this
homegrown success story created for an
exciting future of Esports that Riot
seemed primed and ready to deliver in
2017 they sold a controlling interest in
their company to Madison Square Garden
company the James Dolan owned ownership
group that is also responsible for the
Knicks and that is now also selling CLG
counter logic gaming always got bonus
points in my opinion for supporting
players and teams in Esports where you
know it wasn't necessarily the biggest
stage they got into melee fairly early
and they were an absolutely critical
part of the women's CS go scene for a
very long time and more recently CLG
doubled down on fighting games I think
this was a very smart move giving the
impending release of Street Fighter 6
Tekken 8 and eventually the riot
fighting game project L it's worth
noting that CLG actually signed two
melee players in the past few months
they signed Magi just recently in March
and then in January they signed Corey
Schwab so poor went out for these Pros
because they both just lost lost their
job Cody in particular just managed to
escape the whole Panda disaster so
there's just another example of how bad
things are out there right now we're
seeing the product of all these deals
many of them signed in the mid-20 teens
that Blended the emergent entertainment
medium of Esports with the world of
business in a new and sometimes
unpredictable way these investment
relationships didn't always work well or
maybe in some cases failed to live up to
the spirit of the thing that the
investors initially bought see for
example these claims by FaZe Clan
members or even fans that phase somehow
lost their way went corporate or
something I don't have any inside
information about what happened at CLG
but I do want to say that I never saw
their actions post acquisition by
Madison Square Garden company as somehow
like betraying their identity if your
identity is tied to the very earliest
days of League of Legends well clearly
times change but in the case of CLG they
always felt pretty real to me honestly
clg's Greg Kim Dynasty announced the end
of his tenure running the organization
and on Thursday more voices came forward
to talk about the situation too I'm
really hoping that everyone at the org
who's lost their job can land on their
feet and for the fans I'm really hoping
we get more news soon about what this
means for counter logic Gaming's future
and that is the same James Dolan owned
company that for example is responsible
for Nick's roster decisions
I literally had a Knicks joke in here
and I was like oh yeah my my team's on
the bubble
and their team has clinched a playoff
spot so I can't make fun of them that
sucks